That's New York Democratic
Congressman Jamaal Bowman arguing
with Kentucky Republican Thomas
Massie over how to stop school
shootings like the one in Nashville
that left three students and
three adults dead.
It's understandable that tempers
flare and voices rise in the
aftermath of such horrific events.
When faced with such situations,
the urge to do something, to do
anything is nearly impossible
to resist.
But is Congressman Bowman right
that more guns lead to more
deaths?
The short answer is no.
Over the past few decades, the
number of guns in America has
increased massively, so much so
that there are now more guns than
people in the United States.
Yet federal crime statistics say
that firearm homicides dropped
about 40% between 1993
and 2018.
For other crimes involving guns,
the decline was 71%.
Violent crime did spike during COVID
and while the most recent data is
incomplete, it's clear that
gun related violence remains far
below where it was 30 years
ago, despite more guns than
ever being out there.
That's great news, especially
since reducing the number of guns in
circulation presents not just
immense pragmatic challenges,
but almost certainly insuperable
constitutional barriers.
When it comes to schools, the
2020-2021 academic
year, the latest for which full data
is available, did see the highest
number of school shootings with
casualties this century.
Thankfully, there are too few
violent deaths to generate
statistically significant
conclusions.
But the long term trends show
no increase in homicides or suicides
among students, staff and
teachers.
Overall, schools are becoming safer
and safer, with the government
finding that between 2009 and
2020, non-fatal crime
rates dropped for students ages 12
to 18, from 51
to 11 victimization
per 1000 students.
What about Congressman Massey's
contention?
You know, there's never been a
shooting in a school that allows
teachers to carry.
He appears to be correct, though
contrary to his claim that there's
never been an accidental weapons
discharge by a teacher.
A January 2023 RAND
Corporation study found that
teachers have indeed been involved
in accidental discharges of weapons.
On the larger question of arming
teachers. RAND simply says
there isn't good enough data on
whether doing so would increase gun
violence or reduce it across
eight categories, such as stopping
mass shootings or preventing
suicides.
What, then, is to be done?
Most schools are already gun free
zones or have strict controls
on who's allowed to carry while on
campus.
Many have armed officers on campus,
despite no evidence that such
a presence deters violence.
Recent school shootings, like the
one last year involving Texas,
where law enforcement officials not
only did nothing to prevent an
active shooter, but restrained
parents trying to rescue their
children. Underscore that police
need better and more effective
training.
The 2018 school shooting at Marjory
Stoneman Douglas High School in
Florida highlighted how many red
flags, school staff, police
and social workers had ignored.
It's deeply unsatisfying to
simply say that the people
in charge of school safety need to
do better.
But it might be the best option,
especially if the rush to do
something means trying something
that we already know is impossible,
ineffective, or both.